this is the fun
Oh where there's people you guys reached
out to for the soup that did respond or
didn't that you that surprised you to be
on there are some that way back when
when I was just like man I just see if
Taylor Swift will come on almost with
all those when we ask some crazy
big-name just to see if it would happen
it's been zero but with Taylor Swift as
we had been kind of making fun of all
her songs about how she's had horrible
relationships and she was 19 at that
point but her people said she was she
can't come on as if she had ever been
planning but they were like but we would
like to offer tickets to your staff to
come see her at the Staples Center and I
was like geez she did not have to do
that Wow and now she will be forever in
the you know positive column in my life
but other people are we wait Wayne Evans
pond she could have gone the alternate
route she could have been like [ __ ] you
and [ __ ] KP or just never will they they
wouldn't know our names they would just
never respond maybe I did the real zero
responses usually how it goes gotcha
yeah are there are there any celebrities
and now especially you're doing the show
the Joel McHale show starring with with
Joel McHale with Joel McHale Joel
Anthony Michael Hall I was hooked yeah I
was hoping I got that right where are
there any celebrities that are off
limits for you well know some of them
are jailed uh Sir Robert Blake I I'm not
man I don't think there's a world where
the Kardashians will get permission to
come on the show they won't have you
asked we should I mean because well
they're part of the old joe old network
I was on so I don't think they're gonna
be big fans of that great okay right if
we great if one of them just broke away
the same way that a rogue car - you yeah
you say we could get robbed let's face
it you could get Rob hey Rob wants to
come on listening sure he's highly huge
how many listeners do you have besides
in the car - you're an idiot for
Kardashian's for for for Kardashian's is
worth like 60,000 people
the baby's probably have a big Instagram
following so far well you think about
celebrities naming the babies really
crazy names uh I think it's crazy um I
think that forever when you grew up with
kids in your school that did they had
the hippie name yeah and you're like no
that's I know a guy he's my age and the
first when I met him years ago I was
like I'm Joel and he was like I'm arrow
anyway what
and he goes hippie parents and he's just
acquitted I was like oh okay well and
Rainn Wilson at hippie parents right
yeah yeah he must have right but rain
seems pretty reasonable I just after
you've been here for years like yeah
people call are called rain
yeah but seems like that actually
probably isn't name because I know two
rains Rainn Wilson rain Pryor so there's
two rains so that's that's but yeah
arrow
I know rain well girl I went to high
school with did porn for a little bit
and her name uh-huh her name was rain
from Seattle that was the first that was
her given name no her name is uh her
real name is Emily and I don't go with
porn names you know we're going really
people that were named okay and not Horn
name I did think it was funny that she
took a train and she's from Seattle like
that had to play into it right it seems
like she's like weather oriented it's
it's great if better than I don't know
moss or like being from Phoenix and you
need a my Palin baman would be a
terrible name yeah Paul Allen as a porn
name
yeah I just saw Paul island by the way
at the Blazers game and I saw him
sitting sideline texting and I look at
my dad I go what do you think he's
texting right now like what do you think
that guy and then he your dad was like
did you hear your mom and I are getting
back together probably talking about
that text in your mother that yeah as he
was texting Paul Allen callbacks that
make you cry Paul backs bed still hurts
Blazers win last week
Blazers Rockets game I was up there and
my dad lives in Oregon so he liked the
new uniforms already I like basketball
in the northwest that's that's a real
political answer
I don't okay yeah hear that
Oregon you're that
Paul Allen and Rob Kardashian to avoid
Adams face your uniform how I just
watched the video of you raising the
12th man flag and that is a right
personal goal of mine
I'm sure Brad was that was during the
ESPYs
was it really no that's another callback
what's a bigger what's a bigger
highlight meeting Tony Ventrella while
doing that because I grew up on Tony
Ventrella I grew up on Steve Poole I
grew up on you yeah we grew up relative
but you're much younger than me but we
would not tell by looking side-by-side
that's true yeah you look it's
Neutrogena its Neutrogena eugenics
speaking of new Jennings are you gonna
be that old guy with the 12-pack uh yo
yeah would be the weird guy at the gym
people love that guy with the old guy
inspires the old head well you know the
old head but then they got at that HGH
body that won't make any sense yeah it
can't last for very long
no yeah it didn't a show videos of like
the 85 year old guy with 12 pack abs
like smashing multiple boards yeah doing
karate I'm like I don't know if I want
my old people doing that's like 90s the
new 80 yeah yeah boy they're know it's
like 90s the new yeah because HGH will
reverse it for a while mm-hmm and I
think then at all then you turn into a
gargoyle flap away where did you grow up
okay
Mercer Mercer Island Washington for the
thousands thousands hundreds of
thousands listening to this okay baby
Katie Katie is that true I mean I don't
think you can see Katie's face she just
did this yeah sure yeah whatever you
want
Mercer Island Washington which a lot of
people go iceberg Oh was a lot fun
growing up on an island and I was like
yes but the longest highway in the world
he excuse me in America goes right
through it yeah so it wasn't like it was
a quaint town it's a nice part of town
though there's I mean yeah it's very
affluent now thank you my parents did
well no my parents bought their home for
a hundred grand shut the [ __ ] last year
from a drug
there's like hold this while I'm in
prison Hollywood connections back in
wow that was a smart move well it wasn't
like they thought gotcha
they their what they it was not what it
is now their friends live there in that
man we could live there I mean they
could have lived in Bellevue or some
other Everett suburb yeah
Kirkland Juanita yeah but but it was the
houses were cheap
did you like growing up there yeah it
was great I loved it and we go to high
school Mercer Island High School my step
uncle wasn't a security guy when you
were there was he yes he was rod yeah
rod was great he's the one that broke
the news to the kid we had no son you
know we had no security garden I was
there got you wow that was crazy yeah we
patrolled ourselves that is crazy
actually I mean there was there just no
no and I remember going lights back oh
yeah there was fights but better then I
remember going back and going like
what's uh what's this guy in uniform
what happened I know what are you
talking about
it's where all the security guards and
I'm like oh no I was the error before
that fights would break out but I don't
know just resolved either they or like
everyone would step in they whether you
were a janitor or the principal or music
teacher kids with the refs it was like
street ball well no they would be like
cut this out unless they had money on
them
Wow Wow yeah and then and then you uh
you get in the fights yeah the last I
never had fights a tall guy right oh I
think that oh I do it all the time see
everybody everybody just just for being
tall huh I get it I would be pissed yeah
right take out some knees well they're
not expecting it exactly but no like it
the last time I took a swing at someone
I mean other than my family
sure or JP Anderson or KP which is daily
no I would was I think in eighth grade I
had a fight with Dave Martine
you never forget but then I had a fight
in
College yeah strangely I skipped high
school never see what that was that on
the football field so oh [ __ ] there was
with my teammate and then I well I guess
I was very rough with this while during
basketball practice on the on the high
school team where I I swept through and
made sure my elbow connected with
somebody's jaw so and that that was the
end of the fight so you were the it
wasn't really a fight it was just you
know like this guy's really bothering me
and now I'm gonna sweep them my hand
through it but you were the Bill
Laimbeer of your team I would take that
as a comma ya know I was the guy they
would throw in to go like they would the
coach wouldn't say it but he would be
like get him and he wouldn't have me
injure them on purpose but it would be
you go in there and do the thing that
you do your spaz and throw yourself
around and yeah it wasn't nice now you
don't I'm not proud of it you play get
him on the phone Dave Martin I
so my to them my dad has coffee with his
dad a couple times that's adorable a
week on Mercer Island it's very close
and it's just the way he lives in
Seattle I hear and he looks just to like
see how I think he works for Nordstrom
Wow
I mean are you ever to go there and shop
at Nordstrom just to like be like hey I
don't think you know he's in the
corporate office so okay he's not there
no he said no we you know it's one of
those things when you're young you kind
of resolve that stuff and yeah become
better friends yeah like on the new show
the Joel McHale show with Joel McHale
streaming right now in Netflix yeah new
episodes every 12:05 a.m. oh my god
Keeney on the soup who is now one piece
man yes he is one of my best friends
from grade school from Catholic school
from fifth grade and we had a fight in
sixth or seventh grade and but now we
you know we were thick as thieves after
that for years is that is that the man
who Paul Feig put his head into yeah yes
you've got one of the most I'm gonna go
boil my face you have one of the most
decorated comedy directors putting his
head between a man's butt cheeks yeah
all right are you proud of that Joel
McHale we try to find things to find
butt cheeks all footballs facing
I'll be like hey there's an
award-winning more celebrated comedy
directors the last 10 years why don't we
have wood last week he was looking at
our vintage rotoscope as opposed to the
new ones sure he he was into Vindico on
roto sculptures like this one you can
see her skirt and it shows her ankle
hubba-hubba he's very funny do people
know that he he came to you and KP yeah
yeah bring the show back I don't know if
people know it and they probably won't
know it after this podcast but um Rob
Kardashian will Rob Rob is hanging up
his car keys and gathering his
sunglasses so we can drive down to him
and one of Adam parents one of Adams
parents will know oh yes yeah you know
what this is like is it hopefully
there's like a rule Beetlejuice words it
and joke about it enough it actually
happens
I think we've passed the three sorry
parent should be showing they should be
appearing is that your mom
no I wife a Beetlejuice parents might be
getting back together we talked about
they need to appear as how many one yes
so that wasn't a that wasn't it you look
old honey no that was putting your mom's
name is pudding yeah mmm she a boxer yes
an old she fights in the Jewish
community League oh it's not it's not
physical fights it's just a fight of who
can complain more yeah feel like that's
a stereotype and it's and it is yeah I
said I stand by a [ __ ] bread you got
to get bar Mitzvahed just to prove that
you're not yeah you bar Mitzvahed no I
think about it well because there were
several definitely there were several
dwarf ceremonies that you might think
were bar mitzvahs like I mean there's
the tree ceremony what you don't know
about this clearly I don't you don't
know about the famous Treat ceremony no
do you know what the famous tree
ceremony I mean I've heard rumors every
every dwarf has a tree of course right
this part of your vows was in the
running well but no but in case of the
divorce I do get the tree it's by law
she cannot she cannot touch the tree
that's funny
yeah what's the tree ceremony let me
tell you as I make it up the the tree
the tree ceremony is when a young dwarf
lad
comes of age and now he has the power to
grant wishes
how old is 13 right no 6 because the
ages are doubled in dwarf years oh yes
because you know we don't live as long
it's kind of sad really
yeah I'm 34 which means uh how long does
this podcast last so your wife gets the
money yeah exactly but not the tree okay
yeah trees in your name agree will be
like married you'll be buried with it in
it I'm buried in the tree or they use
they tie you your body to the tree and
burn it and they set the tree on fire
Viking funeral style okay yeah that
means your wife will have to jump on top
of it
sure sure yeah maybe she can build a
house in the trees Swiss Family Robinson
style I mean that's kind of learning
that way I kind of live forever hmm in
in really not live as long yeah I'm
gonna go another five years so Joel when
Paul came to you and said we're fine job
well you'll live up very long yeah very
very very long time yeah when Paul
spelling myself was he bar mitzvah
Jewish wait wait so did you know Paul
prior to all this yes
yeah through just from him being a fan
of the show
raizy and then him at he he would tweet
about the show and like paul feig is
tweeting about the show so that we asked
him to come on years ago yeah so then he
kind of was a mascot in a weird way cuz
except that he was at the world-famous
director very successful movies sure and
then what he hint it when he would come
to the show be like man I just love it I
hope there's never at like what'd he say
yeah I would say I would you like to
show me Paul think this is great and and
we didn't then when the show stopped
then two years later Paul was out
walking his dog in a three-piece suit so
he's casual his dog was only wearing a
vest underdressed
yes Vaseline Paul spats were white is it
B and then he ran into KP and they
started talking about it I had KP and I
had thrown it around like what do you
think what do you want to do right
because like why would you not want to
do me it seems like the most fun job of
all time hmm and it's very fun yeah it
really and but then but when it ends do
you almost as you're feeling too of like
alright well things are just everything
ends at some point so that should we
should just like let that go or like how
many days after you like [ __ ] we should
figure out a way to keep doing it I that
Boyd that was off my mind for like a
year okay I didn't think I kind of was
thought I'll go I'll do it at some point
but I didn't know when that was yeah and
the CBS show started yeah so that took
up a lot of time and I was doing other
things and then but I was always like I
should probably try and do that because
I wanted to I liked doing it very much
and I liked our people and and then I
believe me I can't believe how lucky I
am that someone that Netflix was like
fine we'll give you a shot and so that
worked out great and so that I don't we
didn't really have a time frame gotcha
but then it the CBS show has canceled
and so it worked out great thanks bring
that up at him yeah was there any I
brought up to CBS yeah okay well just
like he brought up his parents divorce
was there any hesitation at all when KP
calls you and says hey Paul Feig wants
to do the show was there any part of
your brain that was like no no no no I
but we had been chatting about it but
Paul really was like we need to do this
now and it's good Paul and
and we're like okay I'm deviant we said
that in the show last week almost a Jeff
Goldblum it's very similar it's close
but he yeah so he we then started
putting the pitches together and that's
when we we didn't pitch to any networks
so it was us all streaming I guess we
pitched to there was a couple of news
companies that wanted to hear it really
we thought that was interesting but yeah
we kind of thought it might probably not
fit but I wasn't like we weren't gonna
not tell them yeah because you could be
edgy on any but I mean being able to
curse um kind of like dude yeah
isn't is there an extra level of like
looseness there's no rules that's
amazing
we were gonna call this were one of the
names of the show was Joel Mikhail's
weekly dump which they were kind of like
can we call it something else that's not
it
[ __ ] and now and now that's a bit and
now it's a bit in the show because Paul
loved that bit and every time you said
Joel McHale his weekly dump he would
burst out laughing he did that yeah so
that was the working title and then
there was a few other they were like can
we just move move away from scatological
thing how involved are you with the
research of the shows and stuff to
people yeah obvious have a team that is
watching everything they're watching
right now yeah I'm not doing my job but
why are they presenting you stuff well a
you I look the second I leave here I
will zip over there and we will have a
clip meeting
awesome yeah well it's yeah that we're
trying to gather things I mean it's
difficult because everything gets viewed
but we're trying to gather things that
aren't as viewed and then we gather you
do a brilliantly everything I see I'm
like I even if I've seen that show
there's certain moments that you just
like miss yeah you some what you're good
at like finding you know not just
getting the really popular like
everybody saw this but like what about
that moment that happened maybe five
minutes after you ordered Japanese movie
called tag no like if everyone was
decapitated I mean you say that but your
but your staff found a Japanese show
people thinking that they're going to
die by the bottom of an elevator falling
out which is just insane that that
exists there's another clip from that
show that went very viral that one was
and that was strangely they only were
doing it to women making them think that
they were going to die in an elevator
and then putting the guy in a box again
I was going but this other one was more
elaborate where a guy went in for a job
interview and there's a group of guys
interviewing him and then just sniper
bullets start coming in and everybody
gets shot and he drops to the ground and
he's trying and he's trying to make it
to the exit but shots are still coming
in and then people are trying to help
him they start firing back they get shot
and he is crying he is crying and
screaming and weeping and believing he's
going to die and there's his wife in the
corner just cackling away and so we
decided we didn't show that because it
had made headlines sure cuz you don't
want to use the clips that are already
no I don't want to use we don't want to
use old unless we find something old
that nobody has seen right then we'll
show it but for the most part we want to
find stuff that's happening now and
that's why we go into things like South
African soap operas and we're throwing
we're showing a Argentinian talk show
this week finally and that that's one
where a woman is swinging a vacuum
around in circles and hits a guy and she
falls over during the chat time which is
really it warmed my heart but you see
these clips and it's brilliant moved to
to incorporate that in the show because
a Netflix is so international yeah right
yeah right well that was probably we
want to expand yeah the audience's but
also when I see these clips I'm like how
is that not already so famous but yeah I
hope you just explained like I think
it's because there's so much out there
yeah yeah and there's so much that we to
choose from especially in foreign
languages that nobody knows and who
would have thought in African language
kids are called [ __ ] and
they say it all the time on that
television show and it's bonkers and
that and that's a joke that you couldn't
do on E but now you can do on Netflix
you absolutely and it's wit I'm sure the
people when they're watching if they're
watching in South Africa they're like
what's the big problem I don't know
so but we don't know yet whether you
know whether like if we show a couple of
Japanese game shows whether Japan's
going like well we're all on board now
let's weekly show we don't know we like
to think we but but we're kind of just
throwing the net wide and hopefully
people we know it does well in the
english-speaking countries which makes
sense because the humor is very specific
to America and you know culture like
that
how many Korean culture when you go back
to the office right now how many clips
are shows when they present you with
that you're kind of Minority Report
style like be like that one that what
like yeah there's a pool with three bald
women where what money where the next
clip is coming from behind the balloons
why cuz because the bald woman told him
to remember it yeah what was her name oh
geez rain Abigail no she was also in the
sweet'n low down with the Woody Allen
movie with oh yeah with if only we had
devices in our pop yes if only they were
right there that Sean Penn was great
movie yes Emily Mortimer yep Mortimer's
result yeah she was but then in that
movie was what's-his-name who I can
never remember his name the Irish act
with a lead Colin Farrell yes I never
can remember his name I don't know why
you want to say first but then he got
clean and sober yes and yeah anyway
that's nice people have to say the Colin
or so how about that crazy story from
last week what what was that one so they
were being stalked or they accuse
someone of stalking them but she had had
the his wife had had an affair with the
stalker shut up
but this is Firth is getting cheated on
yeah but then they
then Colin Furze was like yeah this
happened in the past and now this guy is
bothering us and then the guy bothering
them was like I'm not a stalker
you taught you I've I sent her a text
message and it sounds very horrifying no
yeah he's like I'm not a stalker at all
like we were texting each other no so
he's almost saying like yeah he's my
stalking because it's almost denying
that affair is still going on well I
think it was but he's going like he's a
different guy ya know it's the same guy
but he said if you think he is now
pissed that means like my behavior was
not that of a stalker Wow and you just
you just don't see that happen you just
don't imagine that happening to a guy
like Colin Firth no maybe it's the
accent I don't know me well a lot of
people have that accent pretty probably
right and like an entire country from
worth an entire country has an accent
well I would say that Great Britain even
though there's a lot of dialect right
you got to get outside the tree more
often I'm agree disagree Joel that nope
I mean that's not an argument a lot of
people in Great Britain have British I
know what that yeah this must what they
mean by the Hollywood bubble you just
don't get out you just you hear things
hauling this yes we're telling you yes
he word yeah I I'm a bubble I feel I'm
the voice of real America Joel and
uh-huh does not believe other people
than Colin Firth have British accent I
think they are eight ways to live your
mother I think maybe Jason Statham in
that you're just this Hollywood elites
where you live in your own world I get
it so now you flipped it cuz we thought
you were talking about yourself
not realizing there was more than one
person with a British accent I'm gonna
show you Mary Poppins tonight mmm and
blow your mind is that your housekeeper
yeah okay cool
[Laughter]
thinking of improv we've got Katy is
letting us know that we have to take a
commercial break right this break
brought to you by the Seattle Mariners
nice it's your season tickets now so you
think it's now spring is here please
come to the game Ichiro's back back
that should just be the slogan yeah he
churros back and as good as he was when
he started yeah I mean that bunnies men
don't age yeah if you watch him and I
mean you watched it yeah he stretches
endlessly yes that's why I think he
actually could probably play for another
decade yes he's gonna have to play a
majority of the season too because II
Ichiro's back is a lot better than their
original slogan which was the Seattle
Mariners somebody's gotta lose to the
Angels right well unless it's the early
2000s where the Angels lost every game
to us yes but then one of the Angels win
the well are you yes are you an Anaheim
fan or a Los Angeles fan I was born and
raised in Orange County so I'm an Angels
fan and then my dad listened to Vin
Scully on the radio almost every day so
I'm also a Dodger fan um but he was an
angel so are you a Christopher Lloyd
Toni Los Angeles Angels of Anaheim fan
oh I'm question the dumbest name of all
time Oh a stupidest absolutely it's
naturally Wayne did that really brought
in the Los Angeles yeah they just went
there in droves from Echo Park
no there was in it's the dumbest thing
ever when you're watching a game and the
scores in the upper left-hand corner and
the abbreviation for the Angels is just
la like laa that's just that's bad it's
bad I did the owner does the owner still
think it's a brilliant move I hope not
yeah I was a California Angels fan what
was wrong with that nothing nothing then
they wanted to have Los Angeles people
it's just the more vague you make teams
mm-hmm the less I think people want to
pay I mean they wanted to call it
Earth's Angels but that was already
covered in a song mm-hm you should fire
yourself I should go put yourself in
comedy jail
this is your comedy party you're the one
always saying you gotta get married Joel
what yes yeah that doesn't mean that
after a joke like that rethink
everything I stand by that you do oh
yeah why I thought I thought it was good
whoo I will die I will die all myself
that was good Oh your wife loves you I
know tonight she'll be like don't worry
that was a great job
and when the 35 people who hear this
what do you think you consult your wife
for comedy advice or anyone in your
family sometimes you tell me stories of
your kids saying really funny [ __ ]
well I will so I've done when I do get
like one-off gigs or corporate gigs yeah
I hire they're the two head writers of
the Joel McHale show with Joel McHale on
Netflix dropping every Sunday at 12:05
which is unbelievable by the way I'm so
that's unbelievable knowing it is and it
there's you're not gonna see anything
like Earth's Angels I guarantee that
good but we know like I will read like
we'll have a like a opening monologue
for some something that I'm doing and
Boyd and Brad and I will have kind of
written it and then when I read it to
Sarah if she finds it totally unfunny
then we know it's good really she'll
just be like uh-huh
once in a while she'll laugh and then
we'll get worried you're concerned cuz
well oh no she really liked it what are
we gonna do rewrite the whole thing I
guess and so yeah she's very tough
critic but that's good
how early do you find that out in the
relationship that that's a good gauge
for your your comedy stylings Oh two
weeks she was never I've dated the book
before her I dated people that laughed
at everything I said
which made me uncomfortable yeah and
then I would test it out I would be I
would say something like hey do you love
clarinets and then
yeah and I thought this is odd
it's not right um I feel like a weird
Twilight Zone where you think you're in
heaven you're actually in hell and
they're like everything you say is what
you always wanted to be right thank you
seriously yeah so uh so then with her
she would yeah if I get her I get very
happy if i if i make her actually truly
laugh then it's great I want to buy your
kids they don't they rarely laugh at
anything I do I mean I know this is the
typical mmm response you know the
typical like comedian like their family
doesn't laugh at them but it's true and
I like it because when I get them to
laugh if they're not laughing at the
jokes and I just tackle them and tickle
them in them and then they're laughing
and then they're like this cheating what
did you say you have this bit about what
your son said to one of the writers on
your show to Super Bowl party about oh
right does that happen a lot you don't
have to do the bit but just those
exchanges have yeah yes that make you
proud that there's a little snarky
comedic uh yeah no I mean I it's that I
have this phrase at home when someone
says well you're gonna have to do this
or this or something like if you have a
choice about something I'm and I out my
jokes always like I can do whatever I
want it's not a great joke but now the
kids all say it it's no earth thing when
you're like can you go feat yes no words
like I could go feed the dogs and then
be like well but that's just when I was
unemployed and he would be like why
don't you feed him you don't have a job
and then Touche child right but then but
then he was like Eddie I will something
like Eddie we're going do you want to go
to the movies like it doesn't matter I
can do whatever I want and and I was
like oh this is what's happened that I
yes and if I go if I say do you want to
wear the white shirt of the blue shirt
and and then he'll point the one and if
I said you want to wear the white shirt
he a bit racist
which is how I whenever someone says
wait or something yeah always just go
which is a throwback way back to Ricky
Gervais and in the first season the
office where he was saying that all the
time was like racist so so yes I have
created monsters and
I hope they stayed up prison Ricky -
Ricky trace one of the other four people
Brad from with an accent really yeah
yeah is he is he from this mythical
Island you guys talk about Maria yes
Arne everyone has the same accent yeah
it's Colin Firth Jason Statham Angela
Lansbury yeah Ricky Gervais yeah very
all-american it's weird do you do a lot
of things for their schools like are you
like the cool funny dad that job a you
get asked to do like will you hosted -
no not used to but there's lots of
really I mean it's a private school
thank you but there are a lot like Tom
Lennon is he student there he's a
student very behind his son goes there
and he he hosted the gala this year oh
cool it was really funny now is that
what he's truly like it was he's remark
oh I wish I could show you a video is
there in a very specific school jokes
you'd be like I don't understand but
it's all for the parents yes I mean we
he did put in this joke about they had
this new green space at the school and
the school is right at Franklin and
Highland right in that church that has
the AIDS ribbon on it and as you know it
it's every movie poster in the world is
there yeah so you bring your kids to
school and in their playground they can
stare at the purge poster the entire and
it's it's the size of a building and
then I most reasonable one he pointed
out was the third 50 shades of grey
movie that says oh don't forget to
climax yeah and you know your kids are
all playing like kids don't forget that
and I don't know how you couldn't forget
it
since you're seeing it every four
seconds yeah so that was a very funny is
it is it that like is that a thing that
that people obviously parents are
looking for things to improve the school
and like make it better for their kids
but is that something that people have
brought up that you've heard this how
you think the parenting here is it's all
yeah well that well they're not from
this mythical island of Colin Firth that
you guys know that's all this is a whole
other parent voice
look at the character I'm workshopping
on most pot there have been like all the
Hollywood Hollywood Gary parent you're
right he's great but I think on the
purge poster there were complaints
definitely I think there's been
complaints about when it's ever too
explicit which when you think about it
when you're driving by they're like look
at that man in a bloody apron with a
Gatling gun going down people wearing
masks mm-hmm and then I mean like my
kids will be like you want to see the
purge dad gonna work now you've done
like you've also done a lot of acting
and dramas like that's true and recently
you were in the x-files
wake up you did fantastic now was that
it was small but the though two years
ago was a little bit bigger but I was
believe me I wouldn't do one worked I
would do anything to be on that show is
that just because you're a huge fan of
that
no no it's don't like it I just love you
and Yana Vancouver and as they get
codeine codeine in their tylenol ya know
I was a massive x-files fan and it's one
of the thing before my wife and I were
married we that was the show we watched
together
okay so then when Chris Carter made the
offer I did a Lucy sketch with my cell
phone when my agent was like I don't
know this is something you feel like
doing and I was I'm already in Vancouver
during this phone call I have flown to
Vancouver and I'm waiting I love the
show and I'm really like Chris Carter
and I really like Duchovny and Gillian
Anderson and so so I'm yeah i can't like
when i walked on stage I was just I was
like hey Mulder Scully ha ha ha said
your names out loud I get very excited
the clarinet
yeah I was asking about some specific
clarinet specific episodes he's and
accompany was like ah your fan huh I'm
like yes that's why I'm here I didn't
think some sort of does the rebooting of
sliders
with the terrific Jerry O'Connell do you
do you prefer drama or comedy or do you
just love working above I like money
Radek money better than comedy money no
it's all the same well I guess stand-up
money's better than dramatic money
depends on what's happening but do you
enjoy the prep like vs. uh well first of
all doing show like the Joel McHale show
with Joel McHale streaming Netflix
Sundays 12:05 a.m. a.m. yeah don't make
that mistake by the way I love that how
does that get decided on when it come no
clue okay they just told us and we went
sounds good okay we don't know why I
think it's because maybe it's because
they release a lot of shows at 12:05 on
Friday night yeah and so they wait 24
hours to release the glorified
weatherman comedy show I love him
Sunday at that time I ate some great
song I had a radio show at USC that was
Sunday nights from 12:00 to 2:00 a.m.
got canceled after six weeks because I
would not screen the calls that would
come in and people would curse a lot
oh I think that's a great time but I do
did it - well what is on yeah it was the
only comedy show and that's why I did it
because they only had radio station you
went to USC yeah
are you out of debt I just paid off my
loans about a year ago and I graduated
no five yeah you know five yeah isn't
that crazy Sallie Mae I got a I had the
financial aid and then a couple years of
help and then a lot
I can't imagine though going now you
know I'm saying well I don't think
people could imagine me going back that
would be great Rodney Dangerfield
callback yeah no I think at any I mean I
remember when I went to college people
and can you believe what you have to pay
right I remember hearing Oh NYU is
$40,000 a year so that's and that was
back then and and they were like that's
how much it cost you to live in New York
and I was like that seems impossible
only kings and queens can do that yeah
and now they're like a ton of grand a
year
when you add it all up or something like
close to that seems and ridiculous and
people do not know is that why you like
never say no to anything oh yeah I take
everything yeah I look I'm here we don't
pay Joel Oh
but this danny trejo coffee do another
one another coffee
how many do you have three it was Katie
gonna get that or is she gonna continue
with buying more jaws movie
paraphernalia she is wearing a jaws
shirt and the case on her phone is just
please do not get the milk that's in the
large jug because that is spoiled but
continues to exist in the fridge damn it
why were you trying to poison people
well I mean it would make you stay
longer Oh about last night poster you
got here I guess there's not guys
laughing pissed I'm Danny Trejo don't
copy first time order from it yeah the
coffee was good pretty good right did
you get it at at the corner of Santa
Monica and La Brea I think that's where
it comes from or Highland yeah you drove
all the way down
no I post mated it boom he's doing very
well yeah you can afford that extra look
at all your movie posters around thanks
man now it stays up all the time yeah
trust me there are times when I lock
eyes with Brad in compromising
situations I should not wear your on
your well placed Stairmaster so I can
look at the old Russian man swimming
laps at 8:00 a.m.
do you ever swim out there um that's a
personal question I'd like to move on
yeah in the summer time what about
dessert jacuzzi no and trust me that has
been a complaint of mine since I moved
in mmm where's the jacuzzi
can't have pool toys in there either why
because of the hazard the danger I guess
there's no lifeguard at Dairy to try it
oh I have even when they even when my
name's ed polish landlord said no pool
toy I'd not get an accent sushi no poor
toys in the pool and I go no pool toys
in the pool yeah yeah and I said what
come on and my buddies were down from
Seattle we bought these pool chairs from
Target we had some beers they were like
man we are loving life on vacation away
from our families and then she comes up
no pool toys in the pool and I was like
well come on like
we're not gonna drown she goes you can't
do it I go what would you tell kids with
pool toys no pool toys in the pool I go
great so I put him up on my little patio
there and then I get a text from her
saying the owner of the building was
here and saw your pool toys and said if
you can't have them in the pool why are
they on the patio to which I said the
therapy chairs and then no text back
therapy chairs for some sort of physical
ailment sure dude that's it so they were
even like I see your pool toys I'm not
in the pool but we see them yeah so
what's going on we don't have any pot
but you have these huge bongs out what
are they for
oh yeah water fights yeah all right can
you have a you have a squirt gun in the
pool I mean I ain't looking to find out
there's one side says no diarrhea in the
pool now that I don't think you need to
sign don't need it I think that I think
that should be his day and age it's an
assumed yeah she didn't say that boys
only solid chunks only number one very
hey how many people recognize you from
almost live down here very few really
zero almost really me it's oh yeah I
mean I guess 18 years ago maybe it
happened once or twice I know you did
theater a University of Washington thank
you but what was your favorite play that
you did there or musical or monologue uh
boy no I don't know there was a show
called Polaroid stories I enjoyed very
much nice uh the program you dub right
yes yeah it was very good good I don't I
think it's still pretty good yeah I'll
always like always love Shakespeare
stuff oh really
yeah I always loved that stuff people
look at you mister she does make you
seem like smarter and more it seems like
that ya know I endlessly liked reading
it and Wow and doing it you ever think
about trying to go to London like
performing it like that Globe Theatre or
well there since there's only two people
with the accents
they pretty much get all the rolls guys
tell me for but I don't believe I
believe it in some other world or life I
could I would love to do it but you
should figure that out but then maybe
I'll do maybe I'll do this week's Joel
McHale show Joel McHale Sunday 12:05 in
iambic pentameter
maybe that I'll just do in rhyming verse
just watch I think you may be a
fantastic episode yeah hold the skull
the whole time yeah it'll get a stock
market after they announce the sanctions
how how much of almost live prepped you
for when you move to and for people who
don't know who didn't grow up in Seattle
it was the greatest thing in because
there any if people are a lot of
listeners in see how you do
yeah okay because he's from there so you
know he gets hello young awesome hello
index no one's ever said that really
hello young hub tulips Wow did you go to
the PR fair Auburn yeah when I kept
growing up in Catholic school they had a
special day where they would just take
you down there like go for it that's
great
yeah it was so I loved it y'all fair
just think of any giant fair but it's I
mean kind of famous in the country cuz I
mean I saw hooting the Blowfish there
yeah when they were big well that's not
necessarily something you want to brag
about but Congrats yeah they're
especially you know you being a Seattle
kid really there's so many bands to
choose from Roseanne there too yeah yeah
sure nobody believes you all right it
was Third Eye Blind okay when it was
Paul you have to pay for that yeah that
was just a random joining thought I love
this is gonna be that free now to buy a
damn song that's good 35 grand hey
Steven Jenkins I love that P up fair
because well it's as people don't know
this as young people don't know but
there used to be regional fairs
everywhere where they would bring in
when fart when it would be the harvest
time when everyone was having a great
time and now it's just turned into math
you know a meth Vanessa rollercoaster
city yeah yeah I loved it I still have a
Duran Duran mirror from there
my god could win it to her you won from
what game tossing the ring on the bottom
no it's one of those guys had to guess
my weight mmm anyway oh no no I remember
the guess my weight and I were like
thank you probably got he's like guess
my birthday I was like you'll never
guess that the time for a Duran Duran I
love that you kept it
oh yeah good and then I remember is it I
remember the there was hats you could
win that had a Rambo patch on it
this is what zepho came out sure there
are some there are some young people
going like what but the patch would
always lift out like the patch wasn't
well put on and lo that patch had said
mash mash patch yeah so no well was the
Rambo patch on the ash was printed on it
yeah is it a guy whose job it is to
collect fair prizes I or make them yes
there's I'm there's a thriving um if you
go to like Dave & Buster's yes well
there's one Plex remember that oh yeah
that'll Funplex I still have a laminated
photo of Magic Johnson and Montell
Jordan thumbs up and together like et
style like they're touching their thumbs
at the Funplex yeah man it was behind
the wall it was like do you want a boom
box for no thousand tickets Joel just
made a face like why didn't you lead
with that right when they said they had
a made an appearance though which I
would say was they cut the ribbon at the
opening yeah they wish I remember when
it closed I was like oh no it was
Kendall Gill and Steve pool so the
celebrities had open Funplex they could
probably get Sean camp to do it now I
love camp yes how's he doing good I saw
him I did this podcast with Rappaport at
the triple door and Kemp was on it it
was great
how big is he huge he's not not fat wise
but he's I met him Leonard down oh he's
back there yeah okay he even was talking
about trying to maybe play and said he
was playing and I was like I mean I
don't know I hope that happens I mean it
would be great even like Italy but his
big three Lea's nice we'll look below
yeah yeah I think at this point you
can't know I mean it's hard to mean did
he ever come on almost life I don't
regret it and
Newhouse did right yeah yeah was that
unbelievable that was pretty good and
they were
very funny in the sketch yeah you
Seattle folks you know what they know to
the greatest commentators of all time
yeah
we have died how many years ago like
three yeah can I find any almost live
stuff on YouTube I think almost live
still plays on King every Saturday
really if go on King fives get a
schedule oh this is John Cleese sir this
must be fascinating
I'll telephone Barbie not Harvey I was
so nervous you district is like Silver
Lake it's like the hips you know you
district is rock then oh you district
was no fun and it continues to have
problems I hear I'm always constantly
judging the hens would be the the I
would be considered the white trash
party yeah then so you super nervous for
that oh well because I'm super dyslexic
let's see dyslexic so I'm trying to
think done if I can find almost live on
the on the schedule
there's the 11:00 p.m. news but then it
doesn't give you the 12 a.m.
there it is it is it is on at 12:00 a.m.
and and are these repeats or these
brand-new casts no it's been off the air
for 18 years okay not from an area grew
up I think for the Los Angeles Angels of
Anaheim so I'm not familiar no you grew
up
and then they changed the name of the
team twice go uh no they still they
still run it they obviously don't pay
any of us but what was great about
almost life for me is that they took me
under their wing in John keister and
bill Stanton and Nancy guppy and Pat
Cashman and Tracy Day all them took me
and ste ste well their name Steve Wilson
Tracy Conway and they all took that I
became like their mascot and I cuz I was
an intern and emotion I contributed in
writing and they were there and so they
hired me which was such a I became the
luckiest person on the planet at that
point was that the goal when you were
working there you like eventually
hopefully I can be funny enough in
office situations and pitch ideas that
maybe they'll they'll hire me yeah I
thought oh if this if they didn't think
they were gonna offer me a job but I
thought if I can get some sketch stuff
out of this maybe that will help and
then it allowed me to screw up on live
television and I got all my and I was
still nervous when I you know was doing
anything live but I was it really was
this great place to screw up for a long
time and they didn't and they were very
nice about it so then I got here and I
was like I've been on this show and no
one really knew what you was but yes I
mean that experience rights invaluable
because just being on set and shooting
that much all that's getting comfortable
and building confidence and also the
show was a big hit like who's a huge
missus oh right yeah like I don't know
about now I mean they're all we're all
old now but I mean like how it is for
you not like how can you equate the fame
like at that time because yeah I would
say it was mean Washington high school
it was like I've told you this before
like to see people that you know aren't
you know famous in Beirut but like are
huge and where you are and doing really
funny [ __ ] and no it's a big deal like
that makes you go
oh cool like that yes like this is it's
inspiring it makes you feel like you can
it's not Shannon Creon you know I'm
saying on public access right Wow yeah
come on whatever happened to her I don't
know but you and you know idea we're
talking you know I think for the viewers
Public Access everybody knows what that
is there was a sound sounds like a
disease I'm there
no rules on public access and you could
show anything anything Brody Stephens
and Tina I don't remember is right
member Tatum Brody they had a show oh
okay I didn't watch a ton of it but ours
remember he remember hearing about
almost live was notch's up from but
Shannon Creek ringin you guys actually
did it so funny you and Brooks Macbeth
did this sketch where it was two white
guys acting super hardcore like thugs
and they're in the basement and yeah mom
keeps calling in and on the front of it
it was a public access show but on the
the opening sequence it said that you
just watched Shannon Craig and yeah and
coming up next is these guys she was a
performance artist moments artist was
news yeah yeah paint herself it was
might have been the first boobs I saw
yeah what am i right I'm alive there
that's always literally were no rules
then there were no rules Wow
there was always people going like you
can't show this and then it's public
assets we can do whatever you want
oh that almost live footage of me
ultimately help me get my first was an
admiral agent move down here to move
down here they still didn't but as I
learned very quickly if people don't
know that you've ever done anything they
don't care agents will barely
acknowledge you as a human being let
alone meet with you but then I had this
tape from that show and I had no other
credits and at all zero I had done a
small turn on the fugitive with the
CBS's fugitive short-lived if the TV
show not the movie with Tim
what's-his-name from diner really good
Tim Daly very nice man but but there was
nothing and then the guy was that I
literally the agent said after taking a
weekend I was like so what you think he
was like well it's not a he'll now so so
we'll sign you and that's how so I you
know even though I worked very hard and
almost let just heat when you get here
nobody really cares unless unless you're
doing something Wow
and then what later were your first gigs
that you got here yeah well how was the
move first of all like that was oh yeah
you would I mean wife and kids already
know kids go back then
we bought them later no we I've every
big move right to take I mean just to
come down here Freddie yeah it was
either New York or here yeah an Avenger
I was kind of like we shouldn't go to
New York because all I really want to
try right now is movies and TV I mean
but then it's not a really great
argument because people break out of
there too but they eventually all move
here yeah and then they'll complain
about not living in New York and then 25
years later like you should just move
back to New York because you've been you
now live here forever
but I'm telling you not to like dude
you're [ __ ] almost like like no cuz I
quit almost live pretty much to go to
graduate school gotcha so I could become
an actor and at the University of
Washington nice so that's where I did
all that Shakespeare and stuff like that
and so know that you're classically
trained like this I don't know if it's
classical but I'm trained it wasn't like
it wasn't classical Shakespeare training
rice we learned this kind of Japanese
form of acting and Shakespeare was
incorporated all throughout it I died so
I don't really know you went to grad
school yeah three years yeah three years
yeah and then actually I didn't do that
no but he has way more money much more
successful and the ranch was picked up
for like another season so we're just
hoping to get out of our first year uh
but no I my poor wife I told her when we
were married when we're about at your
marrow you must agree to move to another
city because I'm not gonna stay in good
for you yeah you should have to do that
right and she was like alright and then
I said give me five years just ride on
here yeah I was like you give me five
years to get established if it doesn't
work out I will go back to I will
happily go or unhappily go back to
Seattle and what try to get another
internship on a radio program so so that
was kind of the deal and I started
booking commercials uh but no I my poor
wife I told her when we were married
when we're about to marry you must agree
to move to another city because I'm not
gonna stay in good for you yeah you
should have to do that right and she was
like all right and then I said give me
five years just fry down here yeah I was
like you give me five years to get
established if it doesn't work out I
will go back to
I will happily go or unhappily go back
to Seattle and what try to get another
internship on a radio program so so that
was kind of the deal and I and I started
booking commercials were your parents
support her for the whole thing or were
they telling you to stay in Seattle
where the dollar no my parents they were
they were together
kept telling me all these crazy stories
about Adam
let me guess dad they're back together
no the remarried do each other but but
so so I dragged her down here and said
give me five years and and I had an AI
you know you hustle to get in it you
everyone thinks if I can just get an
agent yes then you realize oh that's the
third not as many they're not as hot
they can do a few things but you really
have to do it yourself
yeah that sounds like a horrible insult
to all agents cuz there are many of them
that are very effective but it is there
is no agent that it goes like I've got
the guy he's gonna be the new Han Solo I
it's because I signed with him last week
and now I can put him in that spot it
doesn't happen so how did you create
your own hustle what did you do to
create your own opportunities and when I
well I was very lucky in that I had a
very uh guy named this guy named sandy
Smolin who was is married to Pamela Reed
who is one of the best actors you will
ever see and if you look her up right
now you go oh her yeah she's been in a
thousand things and he was a television
director and he would always take pity
on me and go do you wanna you want to be
this on this guest star this for I'm
doing he's like I'm doing this diagnosis
murder you want to be on that and I'm
like and of course I will do anything
and so he put me in a bunch of stuff and
then I got very lucky and I booked a
small guest star on you pat recognized
panel yeah oh yeah yeah but she's got
like drama right now she's like queen of
Seattle theater cuz she moved back up
there [ __ ] yeah it's cuz she's she's
from there and so she does stuff at the
wrap
at the acting she's she she's also a
cool life by the way to be to cattle
theater I remember seeing her act I was
like oh crap that's how good the actors
are down there I have two Japanese
sheiks yeah I have to be really good to
be at and then you reaiiy realize she's
exceptional on the level that is hard to
ever get near yeah so I was like oh good
I can be a I'm you know quarter there so
we're fine but no I got very lucky and
lied to get onto Will & Grace I the
audition was for people that were over
six seven and I'm 64 and so I went out
and bought some heeled boots can you
know the store that has these heeled
boots and Skechers outlets or in van
nuys I might need them I got a trip to
Six Flags coming up fine need you say
that there's four coasters I can't get
on I have a season pass uh well I I
still have the boots all right carry him
in a baby bjorn into the park I don't
think there's a rule against babies and
boots no but then that they I saw I got
on that show with no agent and you shall
have the boots no but straight up hustle
I mean like oh yeah I lied to get into
that audition I just stood up very
straight and strangely now I have become
Frank I'd now know eric mccormack and
she was on the show I've known for years
now and they were always really cool and
so but but that that I didn't then I got
an agent out of that and then that agent
dropped me a year later saying that I
was not famous enough to be on Designing
Women
he was like if you come back in four
years after you've been established then
you you might be big enough to be in our
agents yeah makes a lot of sense cuz oh
oh yeah you'll go get more famous then
you'll drop whatever agent you have and
come back to me yeah [ __ ] you it's but
in that it's a weird mentality it's this
weird catch-22 though they only want the
thing that they didn't find and so that
was not demoralizing and then I was with
aka
commercials which I was had been with
and I started and I thought well I'll
just I literally thought to myself I
will be the greatest commercial actor of
all time and I just not because I
couldn't get I couldn't get parts or
auditions for anything else
hmm so then I just started doing
commercials and a woman this woman from
II started bringing me in for different
things
and and then the soup audition was just
one of like 12 auditions I had done it
efore different different yeah yeah so
people you were getting I mean were
people you were doing acting auditions
but how many of those were hosts zero
most were zero I mean that was so you
weren't even thinking about doing never
host no never and so that was just
happened to be and then they were said
like oh this might be a talk soup reboot
but we're not calling it that we don't
know what it is calling it the soup
completely different yeah well it was
first called what the awards and then
really president came in and changed it
to the soup this is ancient history
do you remember crushing the audition
like how did you get to a point where
you at a point where you're like walking
in and you're like alright walk out like
on to the next one like that was how was
rhythm right of just like trying to
forget about it as soon as you well they
said cut here's some clips and come up
with some jokes and so that's what I did
and but I didn't walk out of there
high-fiving the air going like boom
looking forward to it it took six months
because it wasn't and that wasn't
because he was doing a worldwide search
it was because just things move we were
moving slowly and it wasn't a huge
priority and then they brought me back a
month later and then and then I did it
again
and then they were like then I had a
meeting where they said well how would
you think this show should go and and we
kind of threw around our ideas and then
we put together a five minute pilot
presentation which was me on a green
screen with like four clips and that was
the whole pilot as opposed to you know
community that took two weeks right and
and then they picked it up then they
said oh and how much does it cost
nothing great well put it on and they
put it on Friday nights at 10:00 which
at that point in the strange landscape
of television before streaming services
was a ghost who's a it was a shirt it
was just nobody there everyone's out
graveyard and and then that's where it's
luck that which was great because I
realized oh that was the best place for
us to be because jerks if you're gonna
get there was I'm zero expectations as
opposed to like I was on that CB s show
last year and they put him on after the
Big Bang Theory and I thought well in
success yeah I will be buying a Maserati
dealership
yeah and in most likely failure I will
be available because almost every show
has failed after you know every every
show has has that had they hopefully
it's gonna be the next big bang it's not
worked but I guess young Sheldon is
working on that well then and I know
this I don't know people that know what
I'm talking about
in doors was funny thank you it was very
well you have your the cast I will say
was extraordinarily it was and you have
Stephen Fry who is a international
treasure you're all so great with
multicam and you should be on it again
well they cancelled it I stepped on to
the nine jkl set and Martin Thorstein he
chopped locked me and was able to drag
me out of the set because that's where
the world sets would be at what point in
the soup did you do you guys know like
from the internet or from people tell it
that somebody come in like I've got the
numbers you guys are that oh character I
do with gear like a kid who's got a
newspaper read all about it we would get
as the bee's knees we would see the
ratings and we would see the thing
before us have no ratings and then we
would have good ratings relatively to
that time and then the ratings get bad
again and then they started putting this
us after us so it would just be an hour
of the same thing sometimes and I
thought oh well that's a good sign and
then like Julia Roberts told I'm told
told a reporter she was like hey just so
you know I watched the soup every week
and no I will never appear she said like
that in the same sentence I was like
Julia Roberts holy [ __ ] and then other
people would walk up to like in weird
situations where I was like at a Golden
Globes party and odd celebrities would
come up and be like
Cameron Diaz was like watches sure every
week I was like what and I don't think
she remembers now but uh but it would be
little things like that and then you it
would be odd things where companies
would want to start sending me stuff for
free
mm maybe like they'd like to send you
shoes on okay like cool companies yeah
not like kids like it'd be like Reebok
you mean kids the coolest company that's
ever been because how [ __ ] dairy it
is that really dads are great they work
they were great I were my kids I think
possibly the sexy issue when it grown in
high school you write junior high be
like there's the kids they're not
wearing socks I can see you know the
back of their calves and the Catholic
school uniform you're right they were
super hot anyway so I don't get it but
just stuff it was like that would happen
one of the ways that I knew it was going
well because I started getting auditions
for the shows I could never get
auditions for like for pilots no one
would like you're like you have to you
can audition for these two lines for
this one pilot and then all of a sudden
it was would you consider reading for
the lead of this pilot and I was like oh
well that's all different now mm-hmm and
I walk in the room with more confidence
because that or you more pressure to
like crush because I go [ __ ] now I'm
getting these opportunities to just go
more definitely more pressure because I
am a maniac and in a constant state of
panic and anxiety and OCD where I'm like
this will probably be the last job I'll
ever get is that why you'd started doing
stand-up because you realize you're a
maniac and you'd fit right in yes and
the money no uh I love performing so I
crave it
it's an affliction really it is yes cuz
you want it all the time that's why I
started to understand it was because
doing so much theater I was like I need
that life fixed oh where were you doing
theater I mean all in Seattle at high
school and then USC and then afterwards
a couple plays and then I was like I got
a I don't want to do plays anymore
because it's such a big commitment and
and tired of crying in front of 15
people at a small theater in Santa
Monica
you know how you'd like to I'm gonna cry
on stage there during
yeah I'd like to watch that yeah so yeah
and I I do it at it also was a great
insurance policy yeah for many different
reasons not just leave it it also I feel
like it keeps me younger and out of
trouble and not sitting around just
playing call of duty oh you do I played
call of duty last night not one and that
hasn't happened last summer and I was
and I got in bed I was like you are a
degenerate you now are you the guy that
licensable are you the guy that gets on
the headset and talks crap to people
online I don't talk crap Hey I try to I
try to bring people together shot you in
the head but that doesn't mean your life
is over you can do great things
I'll be like hey shamrock Eddie 441 make
sure you've got some Germans coming up
behind you right now I'm playing the
campaign just because I wanted to see
the one player do you pretty game they
have and I have it on pretty hard and I
was stuck in at one place for an hour
last night and I just had to turn off
the TV because it was one my family have
been bed for three hours realize you had
a very important podcast today yeah I oh
I was nervous he's gonna have the heat
poster man I also this could be the last
thing I do
so this podcast yeah before the Polish
[Music]
features no podcast no pool tips I will
stab you right here stab your inflatable
chairs were you were you more nervous to
do this podcast or to meet Eric Bana and
had you met Eric Bana before and by the
way let's just say the guest that you're
getting to do bits on the Joel McHale
show with Joel McHale are [ __ ] great
they're good drew Barrymore arianna yeah
Adam Devine and Justin bell Kristen
Bell's she's been very nice mm-hmm
that Eric Bana bit was brilliant and to
me was one of those things where I was
like oh this can go viral and become an
actual business that somebody makes out
though well there was like I not joking
over a hundred thousand demands for
those Eric Bana banana bandana
and we I think and so on top of that I
was then then I was there like how many
do we have there like we have nine I
know there how much are they cost and
they're like nine dollars a piece even
and I went so that's the end of the show
but this is M week and then so now we've
just bought a few thousand or something
on a discount good now we're gonna give
some away but wait till you see the
Russell Wilson bit this week
what yeah so he came on and he were
making fun of Frank Thomas's new genex
commercials wait a minute I just saw
that maybe was last night and was just
like I I mean I can't but he's he the
only athlete that is doing a supplement
commercial yeah no I mean like like that
it's very odd
no it's and wonderfully I wish to
realized yeah I was like but also it's
like I don't know Frank Thomas so why am
I surprised yeah like Frank could have
always been doing this just know ad
company wanted to back him he could have
been stepping up to the plate being like
I love taking dick pills and everyone's
like what he's like someday this will
pay off he does that how he talks know
that that's my Angela Lansbury but Frank
Thomas okay I played for the White Sox
that's good friend Thomas Bernanke Sam I
know those commercials are very huge for
me yes um but you make fun of that
commercial with Russ yes he always Frank
Thomas oh my god does he just randomly
walk up strange women you'll see no
women walk up to him in the actual
commercial yes I'm believable because
yes
leaning he's posing on a machine right
and he's just like waiting for people to
recognize and they say it over and over
where they go Frank you look right he
goes I am feeling stronger and leaner
which is strange thing to say I think
goes you've been doing this Frank Thomas
yeah yeah well I got this eugenics pill
and I think you should give it to your
husband you'll be you'll be glad yeah
yeah where is Paul sexpun doesn't do
there it's weird he said he'll be
stepping up to the plate and ready to
swing at any pitch your husband will be
hitting home runs you're making a vagina
oh yeah but with Russell you'll see how
did that how you begin to the world
begins to fall apart because we're all
taking too many supplements
my god and she's like a funny athlete he
seems like he's game for whatever he was
game for what it was great he reviewed
the bit and it was like great how did
that even happen because he's got we
reached out to him awesome now is that
is that kind of like where you're in a
situation where you almost get to be in
charge of your own fantasy camp or just
like I what I would like Russell Wilson
to be on my show oh I have made requests
for people that I would love to be on
the show hmm I would love to get Joan
Cusack on the show because I've been a
fan of junkies extra man for real
yes that's a great love it what's your
favorite Joan Cusack moment or movie
there's too many I mean she won the
Oscar for working girl mm-hmm remember
that guys yes I just mean she was really
funny in Grosse Pointe blank yep as she
played and she burned the office Damian
there's nothing she's done that that I
was your ever I mean it's good for
everything she's like Allison Janney
that way
and in that she just every time she
steps on screen you're like ah I feel
good I'm gonna be taken care of and this
is gonna be fun so I would be great to
get her I anybody from Monty Python I'll
have on yeah how many of you know no
just to be great huge comedy influence
for me yes I would love to get like
Eddie Murphy on we great if he would
come on I don't think he will you reach
out though right did you yeah try yeah
yeah yeah I was like get Taylor Swift
again let's see what happens you know
yeah and also but we're like Gabriel
Iglesias is coming on awesome yeah so
because he is possibly the most popular
comedian in the world right now yeah I
mean yes how many Staples Center shows
which is just badness he's he's doing
the chaotic April foolishness show with
him on Saturday
he's doing his set at 8 o'clock hard out
at 8:25 he rushes to a plane flies to
Vegas and then does Vegas at 10 o'clock
he did that a couple years ago yeah well
I don't he's doing it again but who's
going on is she for him
Jeff Garlin he's going army yeah well
that'll be okay
yeah Jeff will be able to obviously hold
his own but that but yeah he's a crazy
amount of energy and like well and he's
adored yeah
yeah we're also having this guy named
GAD who's French oh yeah yeah oh he's
good sit get him get him get nuts GAD
GAD French oh man his last name is like
Elam Elam you yeah College he's coming
on and and we know that he's this
massive star that he can't walk down the
streets of Paris without people running
up to him and bursting out crimes oh wow
yeah and we uh we always kind of go yes
it's great to have a celebrity but we
need celebrities that can deliver yeah
and we want the bits to be funny I think
Bill Nye is gonna come on and that's
gonna be a little bit of our union
didn't you do an episode of don't
understand sky well he was on almost
live in Seattle really that's where he
got his start Wow I did not know that so
I've known him since nineteen points
it's like 94 was when I first met him
Wow probably probably one of the
smartest dudes walking the planet yeah
he is not dumb yeah he will never be
accused of that controversial Yemen from
it's really smart but he does the thing
he doesn't he has the rare gift of being
able to make everything seem
understandable so he can take huge
months bunches of pretty difficult
information to break down and he can
make it pretty simple yeah he does what
I need
that's how Stephen Fry is he can break
yeah he will he'll tell you he'll look
at this cup and tell you exactly how
this plastic came to be and what it's
doing right now and when it will break
down and why they designed it the way it
did and then he will go into the
chemical structure of the plastic then
you'll go are you intimidated by being
around people that much smarter than you
know you want as any smart people around
you as possible because I'll text you
from the dumb people no I guess it's
barely no I make sure all my friends are
smarter than me
mmm that's why I'm not friends with you
guys makes sense actually good that's a
good move on your part when you did the
White House Correspondents Dinner did
you make sure you had riders that have
been with you
for yeah I was the head writers of the
Joel McHale show with Joel McHale
dropping Sunday mornings at 12:05 a.m.
might as well be Saturday night and and
KP Anderson who was the head writer of
the soup forever yeah and now he's the
executive producer so that was one of
the Cabal and then we took joke
submissions and then who from all st.
Thomas yeah Frank Thomas Nomar
Garciaparra McGriff dogs crime oh yeah
windows hey Lord Perry lot surprisingly
great with political yeah now how would
you really technicians from I don't
there was a bunch of writers that we
okay and then how terrible a couple of
them a lot of them were soup writers
yeah
some were I there was a him Conan writer
who could contribute it but it but
ultimately I mean it really just came
down to us me and those three guys doing
it me performing it over and over to
them to them and tweaking it because we
had the set pretty much set over a week
in advance we all we we really narrowed
I mean we were writing for months but we
were narrowed it down and were just
making even to the point where we were
kind of like everybody's gonna have a
game of thrones joke everyone's gonna
have orange is the new black joke and so
we knew Obama was gonna probably do that
just because they were popular show yes
Ana Malaysian airline joke about because
that was the year the airline oh wow
that plane to disappear oh she
disappeared but it was more about how
the coverage was crazy
and it was the only thing anyone talked
about so we so so I would I saw there
and listened to Obama and then would rip
jokes out and throw him away cuz I was
like alright you got that one he did the
game of thrones joke at the Malaysian
airline I so I kept my malaysian air
ally young do you also want to write in
a week in advance everything says you
can have a base in case something does
happen like that week that you can like
add or for the new show we're not for
the set so when you're like having your
slave for that I what are you making to
other sets uh we were we what just watch
the news every day to see if anything
would change we wanted to have something
incredibly for
David nothing really came up so we just
we the theme was that I mean the ending
theme we wanted to kind of hit a bunch
of you have a rapid-fire jokes of that
America is doing so well the things that
we get upset about are not as bad as
what other countries get upset about
like like in like an Afghanistan we said
something like you know in America we
get worried that someone's gonna spoil a
game of Thrones episode we're in his
I've can estancia like oh did you hear
about what's-his-name he got hit by a
drone spoiler alert and don't and you're
like don't tell me who the drone killed
in the village that day and nobama
didn't like that one but our our whole
thing was like let's make fun of
everybody
let's not choose a side let's just go
after everybody's mm-hmm every how and
how was your overall experience there
like meeting Obama oh it was crazy it
was great I loved it I got to have
dinner with the first lady a sat next
door the whole time what'd you talk
about
we talked a lot about pop culture but we
talked about like but we just shot the
[ __ ] yeah she was great and Obama he's
he was really nice he is incredibly
competitive so he wanted to win that
joke thing and that's why he was so good
at it and I've never been a president as
funny as him in modern day I can't I
don't know
close Clinton kind of threw out a bit
mhm and then of course George Bush was
another line slide by Colbert now
probably the most famous right one but
but I yeah it was ultimately the most
fun thing I've done in proper fun just
because of the whole thing yeah like the
dinner yeah it was I mean but yes
there's other I mean I've done like
being on community was one of the most
fun things I ever did but that was sort
of lasered they're very concentrated
time where the pressure was I've now
I've never been nervous since mm-hmm so
I think the only time I'll be more
nervous as if a plane is going down or I
don't know I'm I get wrapped around a
tree in my car and fuels leaking out and
then there's
I don't know I don't know what would
make me and Brad jumps out of it and
goes hey my hat my house right so yeah
I'll take out my Treacher
this is my tree my bar mitzva trade
callback anyway wait why it was warm
it's obviously five more minutes
yeah time already yeah why was community
love up there oh well I probably see
reasons obviously being on a hit show
yeah in the office seems like the
[ __ ] dream with a with the killer
cast yeah no we knew the scripts were
fantasies invert an was gone but uh but
each script was it was dynamite and the
only the hours were always insane
because we were making a movie every
week but I knew every day when I was
like there is it's so difficult to get
this level of writing every week yeah
there's I was like this will be if this
ever happens to me again
it will be lightning striking twice in
the same spot on Brad Street yeah and so
so I wasn't I I you know I was like
thank you God every day for these great
scripts yes there was insanity onset
sometimes but every job situations gonna
have issues sure with that many people
working together and high-stress
situation yeah and but we were trying we
were pulling off something that was
trying very hard to make something
different and I think it happened and
have that many characters and have it
that evenly spaced out like with
dialogue and Mike Joe like it was you
know like I haven't seen a show do that
you know since really it was it was
really a believe me I would dance Dan
and Dan was the best rider I mean for
making a show like that's the best
writer ever worked with yeah and the
proof is just looking at what that cast
has done since like pretty much everyone
has gone on between Donald and Alison
and yourself like everyone's moving on
to doing yeah everyone's were more
amazing things everyone everyone is
working and thank God Donald's though
his careers bombed does he does he take
your texts anymore um he'll take every
9th text so the 9th usually it's an
emergency text yeah they're like 9-1-1
Donald come help me
I'm trapped I'm trapped in the LA River
and then you'll see usually show like no
I've got a script I like can we thank
you so much for doing this by the way
thank you how long did we do about our
15 which is about what average yeah yeah
we usually an hour I mean okay we do two
hours with you for you I know I you ever
too long by the way that's too long and
people get is people get bored I'm sure
I'm not in trouble
good okay can we end with a song all
right ladies you don't have to sing I'm
gonna ask you some rapid-fire questions
you can just respond to this I didn't
realize what a high-class
production this is oh yeah we do you
have the rights to this song it's
karaoke version it can go for fifteen
more seconds and then we have to pee and
rapid-fire questions this is what
everyone looks forward to in the podcast
absolutely Marc Maron Marc Maron does it
all at a lot of rapid-fire yeah Marc
Maron was here and parked in a handicap
plus a driveway guys got his car towed
yeah he must have not been happy
that's the authentic angry marriage all
right favorite sports stadium pass a
Twitter Oprah Ellen or Oprah yeah Safeco
Field boob or boobs or boobies boobs
handshake or high-five
come on handshake even though you were
part of the high five and white guys
yeah no I retired that hand all right
I don't know I hate fist bumping you do
I hate it why this is dumb it seems like
something Carson Daly would do what's
why bring Carson Daly into this he's
very nice man he is and he made a lot of
things popular through TRL and I think
the fist bump was one of them I feel
like this is just a theory that you're
making up can I have Carson Daly's
number yes beany your hat beanie or hat
depends on the weather
yeah you have to be a dick about it fly
and I want Y your dry fly or Drive yeah
driven to the airport
oh he's classy
that onto the air you know right onto
the tarmac this is great chicken or
steak
rapidfire a steak but chicken don't
overcook chicken which everybody does
that's when they gets ruined is that a
dig at Wolfgang Puck no all right
that was the next day get your mom's
cooking what should be happening tonight
for their wedding reception I'm so happy
that was the last question are they
getting bags yeah Thanksgiving or
Christmas Christmas griffey or Russell
Wilson
Russell Wilson only because he's playing
right now and not him desperately on the
Joel McHale really though he really
needs to be a play-by-play guy because
he's remarkably funny he is that's good
to know
would you rather fight a kangaroo or a
bear I hire someone to fight both of
those Ukrainian soon Clarissa explains
it all our Hannah Montana I don't know
what the first thing so Hannah Montana
it was basically Nickelodeon or Disney
question
oh well neither am too old
great good answer yeah favorite thing
your kids said in the last year what a
[ __ ] that works and yeah advice for
young comics you like stand-up comics or
yeah keep keep at it don't wear sport
coats the stage that's actually sound
advice yeah don't wear sport coats and
you're making a weirdo you are you at an
office uh at an office wearing a sport
coat no yeah no just but don't go on
stage with a sport coat great Wow but
you young comics just do it you got to
do it like six thousand times before you
know you're good or not right yeah yeah
something like that
ten ten thousand hours theory yeah is
that a theory yeah that once you do
something for ten thousand hours then
then you're good at it or or you suck
super failure yeah I've heard the Frank
Thomas theory which is ten thousand
pills right and then stronger and leaner
thanks Jill and your dick scrape thank
you for doing this thank you for having
me today Joel McHale this is a perfect
ending because I have to urinate
right here oh it feels so good such
relief
you
great Wow but you young comics just do
it you got to do it like six thousand
times before you know you're good or not
right yeah yeah something like that
ten ten thousand hours theory yeah is
that a theory yeah that once you do
something for ten thousand hours then
then you're good at it or or you suck
super failure yeah I've heard the Frank
Thomas theory which is ten thousand
pills right and then stronger and leaner
thanks Jill and your dicks great thank
you for doing this thank you for having
me hey Joel McHale this is a perfect
ending because I have to urinate fine
right here oh it feels so good such
relief
[Music]
slow down
[Applause]
[Music]